F
AN ILLEGAL'S VOTING.
GIVE ME A VERY SMALL SNAPSHOT
THAT I CAN TAKE AND CHAMPION."
PAULA REID IS "OUTFRONT" FOR US
TONIGHT.
PAULA, YOU HAVE HEARD THE NAME
MARK MEADOWS THERE A FEW TIMES,
BUT WITNESS AFTER WITNESS AFTER
WITNESS THE TRANSCRIPT AFTER
TRANSCRIPT, MEADOWS' NAME COMES
UP AGAIN AND AGAIN AND SEEMS TO
BE THERE FOR EVERYTHING.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND WHILE THE COMMITTEE MADE A
CONSCIOUS DECISION TO FOCUS ITS
FINAL REPORT ON FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, IT'S CLEAR FROM POURING
OVER THESE TRANSCRIPTS, DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF THEM, CLEARLY
ESTABLISH THE FACT THAT MARK
MEADOWS WAS AT THE CENTER OF
THIS MULTIFACETED PLAN TO TRY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
JUST GOING THROUGH A FEW
EXAMPLES HERE.
IT STARTS RIGHT AROUND THE TIME
OF THE ELECTION.
MARK MEADOWS IS THE ONE TEXTING
WITH DONALD TRUMP JR. ABOUT A
PLAN TO TRY TO KEEP TRUMP IN
POWER.
A PLAN THAT LOOKS EXACTLY LIKE
THE ONE THAT WAS ADOPTED OVER
THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
MEADOWS WAS INVOLVED IN
PRESSURING STATES TO OVERTURN
THEIR ELECTIONS.
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT HE WAS THE
ONE TRYING TO KEEP SOME MEETINGS
ABOUT THE ELECTION RESULTS OFF
THE BOOKS AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
ALLEGEDLY BURNING PAPERS IN HIS
WHITE HOUSE OFFICE, INCLUDING
AFTER SOME MEETINGS WITH A GOP
REPRESENTATIVE WHO WAS INVOLVED
IN PRESSURING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION RESULTS.
WE ALSO KNOW MEADOWS IS THE ONE
MANY PEOPLE REACHED OUT TO ON
JANUARY 6th TO CONVINCE THE
PRESIDENT TO COME OUT AND BE
MORE FORCEFUL IN DENOUNCING THE
VIOLENCE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
WHAT STEPHANIE SAID IN HER
INTERVIEW, HOW SHE TALKED ABOUT
HOW THE FORMER FIRST LADY DIDN'T
REALLY TRUST MEADOWS, AND HAD
SOME CONCERNS BECAUSE SHE WAS
ESPECIALLY, ACCORDING TO
STEPHANIE'S TESTIMONY CONCERNED
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO JUST TOLD THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHAT HE WANTED
TO HEAR, AND SHE FELT LIKE
MEADOWS WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
NOW HE IS -- MEADOWS IS THE
COMMON FACTOR IN SO MANY OF
THESE SCENARIOS AND SO MANY OF
THESE EVENTS.
AND NOW IT WILL BE UP TO SPECIAL
COUNSEL JACK SMITH TO ESTABLISH
AND INVESTIGATE WHETHER THIS IS
ANY CRIMINAL CONDUCT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
>> AND THAT WOULD BE THE NEXT
STEP.
ALSO, MEADOWS MENTIONED IN THE
TRANSCRIPT FOR DONALD TRUMP JR.
WHO WAS ASKED ABOUT THE TEXTS HE
SENT TO MEADOWS ON JANUARY 6th.
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAD A FEW DIFFERENT TEXT
EXCHANGES.
THE ONE YOU'RE REFERRING TO
HAPPENED WHILE THE VIOLENCE WAS
TAKING PLACE ON THE CAPITOL, AND
DONALD TRUMP JR. REACHED OUT TO
THE FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF TO GET
HIM TO CONVINCE HIS FATHER TO
COME OUT AND TAKE A MORE
FORCEFUL STAND AGAINST WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
NOW OF COURSE THE COMMITTEE WAS
CURIOUS, WHY DIDN'T YOU JUST
REACH OUT THE YOUR FATHER
YOURSELF.
HE IS AFTER ALL YOUR DAD.
HE SAID OF COURSE HIS FATHER
DOESN'T TEXT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO CALL HIM
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT ANYONE TO
OVERHEAR THE CONVERSATION.
SO HE WAS PRESSING MEADOWS TO
CONVINCE HIS FATHER TO DO AN
OVAL OFFICE ADDRESS.
HERE IS SOME OF WHAT HE SAID.
HE SAID, LOOK, I THINK THAT THIS
TAKES TIME.
I WASN'T IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO
HELP.
I WASN'T THERE.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED,
BUT I DID THINK WE JUST NEEDED
TO BE MORE FORWARD AND MORE OUT
THERE AT THAT POINT.
NOW INTERESTINGLY, THE
TRANSCRIPTS INVOLVE A LOT OF
INSTANCES WHERE DONALD TRUMP JR.
JUST COULDN'T RECALL WHEN ASKED
MORE SPECIFIC DETAILS,
PARTICULARLY ABOUT WHY HE
THOUGHT HIS FATHER'S TWEET ABOUT
THE CAPITOL POLICE WAS NOT A
SUFFICIENT RESPONSE.
>> PAULA, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING ALL THAT.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY STEPHANIE
GRISHAM.
YOU WERE IN THE ROOM WHERE IT
HAPPENED, OR WHERE SOME OF IT
HAPPENED ANY WAY.
LET'S START WITH MARK MEADOWS.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF
STAFF.
YOU WOULD IMAGINE THAT A LOT OF
THINGS GO THROUGH HIM.
HOW MUCH BLAME DO YOU THINK HE
BEARS FOR WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th, KNOWING WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW FROM THE TRANSCRIPTS
AND THE JANUARY 6th REPORT?
>> WELL, I'M DISAPPOINTED TO SAY
I WASN'T SURPRISED BY, YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY TALKING ABOUT MARK
MEADOWS AND HIS ROLE IN THIS.
I THINK AS CHIEF OF STAFF HOLDS
A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY, AND HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SHUTTING PEOPLE
DOWN THE MOMENT THEY WERE
TEXTING WITH IDEAS SUCH AS DON
JR.'S IDEA TO HAVE HIS FATHER
KEEP POWER.
HE SHOULD HAVE SHUT THAT DOWN.
HE SHOULD HAVE EVEN DEALING WITH
THE IRE OF THE PRESIDENT OR AT
THOUGHT OF BEING FIRED, HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TELLING THE
PRESIDENT YOU LOST, WE NEED TO
MOVE ON.
CERTAINLY ON JANUARY 6th, HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TELLING HIM TO
GO OUT THERE AND SAY SOMETHING.
AT THE VERY LEAST, THAT'S WHERE
THAT DAY I RESIGNED.
MAYBE HE SHOULD HAVE RESIGNED.
I THINK SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
SOMEONE LIKE THE CHIEF OF STAFF
RESIGNING IN PROTEST WOULD HAVE
MAYBE MADE THE PRESIDENT DO
SOMETHING.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW THIS.
IS ME SPECULATING.
BUT I HOLD HIM VERY MUCH IN
CONTEMPT WITH ALL OF THIS.
>> YOU ALSO TESTIFY WHAT YOU
CALLED A COMPLETE 180 FROM
MELANIA TRUMP IN THE WEEKS
RUNNING UP TO JANUARY 6th AND
HER REFUSAL TO CALL FOR PEACE AS
THE DEADLY INSURRECTION WAS AT
FULL STEAM.
YOU TESTIFIED IN PART, QUOTE,
AND I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
THIS, BUT I'M REPEATING IT.
SHE HAD STARTED TO, IN MY
OPINION, DRINK SOMEBODY'S
KOOL-AID THAT PERHAPS THIS
ELECTION WAS STOLEN, AND THAT
BECAUSE I KNEW SHE WAS UP THERE
WITH THE CARPET, AND I WAS
WATCHING VIOLENCE TAKE PLACE AT
OUR CAPITOL, AND SHE JUST
LITERALLY SAID NO TO ME, WITH NO
EXPLANATION.
I MEAN, I KIND OF WAS LIKE JUST
FU.
I WAS SO, SO DISAPPOINTED IN
HER.
NOW YOU JUST MENTIONED YOU
RESIGNED THAT DAY.
WHAT WERE YOU GETTING FROM HER?
WAS IT YOU WEREN'T GETTING
ANYTHING, OR SHE STARTED TO
BELIEVE THE ELECTION LIES?
>> SO, AFTER THE ELECTION, SHE
STARTED TO BECOME MORE DISTANT.
AND EVERY NOW AND AGAIN SHE
WOULD SAY SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT
WITH THE ELECTION, SOMETHING BAD
WENT ON HERE.
THAT JUST WASN'T HER.
SHE WAS ALWAYS VERY PRAGMATIC,
AND SHE NEVER REALLY BELIEVED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
SHE WAS ALWAYS ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE TO SPEAK OUT AND ADVISE
HER HUSBAND WHEN HE WAS NOT
RIGHT ABOUT SOMETHING.
SO IT STARTED OFF THE ELECTION.
MY PERSONAL OPINION SHE KNEW
THEY WERE LEAVING AND SHE WAS
GOING TO GO BACK TO FLORIDA AND
BE IN VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY WITH
HIM.
I THINK IT WAS ABOUT SURVIVAL
AND SHE DIDN'T WANT TO START
ANYTHING WITH HIM.
AGAIN, JUST MY OPINION.
ON JANUARY 6th WHEN I SENT HER
THAT TEXT, THE FACT THAT SHE
DIDN'T SAY WHAT IS GOING ON, WHY
WOULD WE EVEN PUT THAT OUT TOLD
ME SHE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND THE FACT THAT SHE KNEW WHAT
WAS GOING ON AND JUST WROTE BACK
NO WAS SOMETHING I COULDN'T
STAND FOR.
I HAD TRIED TO RESIGN A FEW
TIMES BETWEEN NOVEMBER AND
JANUARY, AND SHE'D ALWAYS TALK
ME OUT OF IT.
BUT THAT DAY WAS JUST THE LAST
STRAW FOR ME AND SEVERAL OTHERS.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU LASTLY
ABOUT CASSIDY HUTCHINSON WHO
TESTIFIED, WE ALL SAW THAT,
BEING TOLD THAT TRUMP WAS LIVED
THAT THE SECRET SERVICE WOULD
NOT TAKE HIM TO THE CAPITOL
AFTER HIS SPEECH ON JANUARY 6th.
BUT YOU TESTIFIED, QUOTE, EVEN
IF SECRET SERVICE HAD GIVEN HIM
PERMISSION, THAT MAN WAS NOT
GOING TO MARCH DOWN THE STREET
WITH PEOPLE.
I JUST KNOW HIM.
HE IS AFRAID OF PEOPLE.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO THOSE
THINGS.
HE WAS JUST RILING UP A CROWD
THAT YOU COULD TELL WAS ALREADY
ANGRY.
WHAT MAKES YOU SO SURE ABOUT
THAT?
>> JUST OBSERVING HIM AND
KNOWING HIM FOR SIX YEARS.
HE WOULD OFTEN, YOU KNOW, SAY I
WANT TO GO OUT IN THAT CROWD.
AND HE KNEW THE SECRET SERVICE
WOULD TELL HIM NO.
IT WAS ALMOST A LITTLE JOKE
BETWEEN SOME OF US THAT HE KNEW
WHAT HE WAS DOING.
I THINK HE SAID I'M GOING TO GO
WALK WITH YOU TO RILE PEOPLE UP
AND TO GET THEM TO ACTUALLY GO
TO THE CAPITOL.
I BELIEVE HE GOT ANGRY IN THE
CAR.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
BUT I THINK IT'S ALL FOR SHOW.
THAT IS HIM.
I THINK ANGRY THAT DAY, AND HE
PROBABLY TOOK IT OUT ON SECRET
SERVICE.
>> STEPHANIE GRISHAM, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US AND
GIVING US INSIGHT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, JENNIFER ROGER,
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
THE TWO PEOPLE THE COMMITTEE
REALLY SEEMED TO FOCUS ON ARE
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
WHAT KIND OF THINGS COULD
MEADOWS FACE IF DOJ DOES DECIDE
TO PROSECUTE HERE?
>> WELL, SARAH, HE COULD FACE
BASICALLY EVERYTHING THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT COULD FACE.
I MEAN, MARK MEADOWS SEEMED TO
BE THE CENTER OF THIS
CONSPIRACY.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN ALL OF IT.
THE PLOTS TO PRESSURE STATE
ELECTORS, THE PLOTS TO PRESSURE
STATE LEGISLATURES, THE FAKE
INITIAL LAWSUITS THAT WERE
FILED.
HE WAS IN THE MIDST OF REALLY
EVERYTHING ALL THE WAY UP TO
POTENTIAL INSURRECTION CHARGES.
SO I THINK THAT WHATEVER THE DOJ
IS LOOKING AT WITH RESPECT TO
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP ALMOST
CERTAINLY ALSO APPLIES TO MARK
MEADOWS AS WELL.
>> SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY CHARGES,
WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE CONVICTED OF
THAT, THE OATH KEEPERS.
THAT'S 20 YEARS POTENTIALLY IF
FEDERAL PRISON.
THESE ARE REALLY SERIOUS
POTENTIAL CHARGES.
ONE OF THE TRANSCRIPTS RELEASED
TODAY WAS FROM LONG TIME LOYAL
TRUMP AIDE STEPHEN MILLER.
HE SAID, QUOTE, IT'S EXTREME OR
OUTLANDISH TO THINK TRUMP OR
ANYONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD
HAVE WANTED ANYTHING OTHER THAN
PEACE AND HARMONY ON JANUARY
6th.
THAT SEEMS TO FLY IN THE FACE OF
WHAT WE SAW COMING OUT OF THEIR
MOUTHS.
BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY TO STEPHEN
MILLER?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S FUNNY, SARA.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK WE'RE
SEEING IN THESE TRANSCRIPTS, AND
I KNOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN THEM ALL
YET, BUT I'M REALLY STRUCK BY
WHAT WHAT'S NOT THERE.
PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO LOOK
FOR ELEMENTS THAT SUPPORT
CHARGES, EACH ELEMENT BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO LOOK
FOR EVIDENCE THAT UNDERCUTS
THAT.
THEY NEED TO KNOW IF THERE IS
ANY EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE IN
THERE.
STEPHEN MILLER IS THE TYPE OF
WITNESS THAT WOULD TRY TO
PROVIDE THAT.
BUT SAYING GENERAL THINGS LIKE
OH, YOU'D HAVE TO BE CRAZY TO
THINK THAT ANYONE WANTED
ANYTHING OTHER THAN PEACE, OR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S SPEECH
WAS VERY PEACEFUL, THAT'S NOT
EVIDENCE LIKE THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY NOT SEEING
IN ANY OF THESE TRANSCRIPTS, AT
LEAST NOT YET IS EVIDENCE THAT
UNDERCUTS WHAT THE COMMITTEE'S
CONCLUSION IS.
AND SO IF I'M A PROSECUTOR SO
FAR I'M LOOKING AT THIS BODY OF
EVIDENCE AND SAYING THIS LOOKS
PRETTY SOLID FOR CHARGES, AND
I'M NOT SEEING ANYTHING
CONTRADICTING THAT.
AND STEPHEN MILLER IS THE SORT
OF WITNESS WHO WOULD WANT TO
PROVIDE THAT SORT OF INFORMATION
IF HE COULD.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE SEEING
HIM, DON JR. AND OTH